o lado pessoal do que falar andar que
sejam muito bem vindos e mais um vídeo e
eu não consigo ouvir a minha voz que
esta [ __ ] do cheque login alguém cima
da quina desapareceu o ipad
vamos vamos fazer nenhum ganho já porque
eu já estava em estudo encomendado por
vocês vocês disseram no twitter por eu
julgar o antigo titular está aqui
qualquer coisa por outro carro eu posso
tocar aqui aí ficou escura certas e 10
disseram é que tanto a estrutura é por
isso que os dois jogando alguém abriu a
porta é aquilo vai ai fosse um zumbi é
isto é uma velha itália
ai ai ai ai porta da casa de banho em
abril a ocupar a posto no papel eu acho
que eles não querem matar o que está a
dizer isto é mau e supostamente e
militar falar e aí [ __ ]
ai ai ai está muito alto a introdução
ligou a televisão ligou meu deus senão
vamos ser 24 e não quero e não quer
saber e não quero saber fomos pra sala
vamos prestar atenção está muito luxo
eu acho que foi uma coisa importante e
não possui nada porque fugir ai ai
é no hit tem algum botão que primeiro eu
não estou sendo pai
o que dispensou nesta potável
o uma casa do em finalmente encontrei na
casa de lincon luz tem uma mensagem que
nunca choque registo não conseguem matar
o espanhol surge ela tá fugindo dos
palhaços que o palhaço estava deitado no
chão uma porta achar uma porta os contos
conosco dentro da banheira rápido a
desculpa desculpa ele é meu irmão e pai
né eu não posso virar costas pra ela né
a jesus espera ela está tudo saindo mas
já fui aí
tranquilo tranquilo eu só quero abrir a
porta em haia está cada vez mais perto
de mim não posso virar as costas e agora
o meu desejo anos
vamos correr ae
ela tá escuro
tudo escureceu e lúcio que está lá por
agosto todas minuta foi abrir portais da
escolha que também vamos acender a luz
rap corre corre até chegar num cobertor
a itaqui um obstáculo a uma caixa a uma
cadeira não sei o que está aqui mas tem
isto é um obstáculo piscina luz
aí sim as instruções ou agora que mizael
não precisa de instruções
ai eu quero um abraço ela quer um
abracinho mas eu não vou dar um abraço
incêndio é mão e eu não quero brincar
contigo é mau e ainda custou estou só
tom não só não é que eu sinto não
guardam as coisas velhas né ai meu viu
junho
vamos lá mais uma vez
ai ai ai está aqui ainda agora começou e
ela já tá aqui na nenê
a italiana lucia vou tentar abrir aquela
porta estava não ok
ai ai no curupira sendo buscar assassino
luz botafogo e meu cérebro e não existe
o sistema então vamos escolher a pagar
luzinha paga para propaganda do
bardallos com o sócio não paga a um
computador e um quintal e um ps alguém
comendo uma pizza aqui espero lá sendo a
lusa quer ver o que se passa aqui celas
para até cozinha ou à sua porta
aí abri a porta sem luta ai ai ai nao ta
dont look até eu não posso olhar para
elas não assusta não é isso
joca entra já na cozinha o que eu vou
fazer aqui eu preciso de ganhar uma faca
né eu não agarra as coisas porque as
coisas que eu preciso para matar e
marion não deixa agarrar eu não consigo
abrir o frigorífico não dá atrai
ela já entrou na cozinha como é que
possível elas vão descobrir o professor
português deixou por tudo isso o que o
meu deus foi meu deus oh meu deus
o mercosul é o que sempre lutei com o
pai não dá não dá pra ficar steel mill
não dá não dá eu desisto eu desisto
o foco é mostrar a moça apareceu atrás
de mim no botafogo ela vai transmitir o
wii já não sou eu que tenho que fazer
meu nome funciona se o jogo sujo nené
pessoal pessoal vamos ficar porque é
senão eu nem quero saber se ele vai
ficar porque não grande eu não quer
saber
este oe chutar não vão chegar porque com
este vírus para que vocês tenham gostado
de saber quanto você é um wiki favorito
e por favor não peçam pra ficar mais
distante ele não tá este momento foi
medo sério e é isso fique bem até a
próxima